hey everyone welcome to this video on
the installation of kali linux if you
want to learn more about kali linux and
why is it beneficial for users when
compared to normal operating systems an
explanatory video is linked above so you
can click on that video before
proceeding further
there are multiple ways to install kali
linux we can either install it on a
normal hard drive in a virtual machine
software such as vmware or virtualbox or
we can do that in hard bare metal
machines now for the convenience of
explanation we're going to install kali
linux today on a virtual machine
software known as vmware
vmware is able to run multiple operating
systems on a single host machine which
in our case is a windows 10 system
to get started with kali linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image file
we go to get kali
and as you can see there are multiple
platforms on which this operating system
can be inverted
as per our requirement we're going to go
with the virtual message section as you
can see it is already recommended by the
developers
this is the download button which will
download a 64-bit iso file we can
download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet
after clicking on the download button
we can see we have a winrar archive
which will have the iso files
for now we have downloaded the iso file
and it is already present with me so we
can start working on the vmware side of
things
once the iso file is downloaded we open
up vmware workstation
go to file and we create a new virtual
machine
in these two options it is highly
recommended to go with the typical setup
rather than the custom one the custom is
much more advanced and requires much
more information from the user which is
beneficial for developers and people who
are well versed with virtualization
software but for 90 of the cases typical
setup will be enough
here we can select the third option
which will be i will install the
operating system later
in some operating systems we can use the
iso file here directly and vmware will
install it for us but for right now in
the case of kali linux the third option
is always the safest
kali linux is a linux distribution so we
can select linux over here and the
version as you can see here
have multiple versions such as the
multiple
kernels every distribution
has of a parent distribution for example
kali linux has debian and there are
other distributions which are based or
forked from some parent distribution
kalinas is based of debian so we can go
with the highest version of debian which
is the debian 10 point x 64 bit
go on next we can write any such name we
can write
kali linux so that it will be easier to
recognize the virtual machine among this
list of virtual machine instances
the location can be any location you
decide to put by default it should be
the documents folder but anywhere you
put it will hold up all the information
of the operating system all the files
you download all the configurations you
store everything will be stored in this
particular location that you provide
when we go next
we are asked about the disk capacity
this disk capacity will be all the
storage that will be provided to your
virtual machine of kali linux think of
your windows device
if you have a one terabyte of hard drive
you have the entirety of the hard disk
to store data on how much data you give
here you can only store up to that
amount of data not to mention some
amount of capacity will be taken up by
the operating system itself to store its
programs and applications
for now we can give around let's say 15
gb of information or if his recommended
size for debate is 20 you can just go
ahead at 20. it depends on the user case
if you are going to use it extensively
you can even go as high as 50 or 60 gb
if you have plans to download many more
applications and perform multiple
different tests another option we get
over here is storing virtual disks as a
single file or storing them into
multiple files
as we already know this virtual machine
run entirely on vmware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
we're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over here
instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible
for all scenarios except it is much
easier if the split the virtual disk
into multiple files
now even if this makes what
porting virtual machines easier from
either
system to system or
software to software let's say if you
want to switch from vmware to virtualbox
or vice versa the performance takes a
small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual list as a single
file if you have no purposes of ever
moving the virtual machine even if you
do it's not a complete stop that it
cannot be ported it's just easier when
using multiple files but in order to get
the best performance out with the
virtual machine we can store it as a
single file over here
this is a summary of all the changes
that we made and all the configurations
that have been settled until now
now at this point of time we have not
provided the dot iso file yet which is
the installation file for the kali linux
that we downloaded from this website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on finish
and we have kali linux in the list
now
to make the changes further we press on
edit virtual machine settings
the memory is supposed to give the ram
of the virtual machine
so devices with ram of 8 gb or
below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance issues and the host system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my windows machine takes about 2 gb so i
have 6 gb of memory to provide although
if you provide all of the 6 gb it will
be much more difficult for the host
system to run everything properly so for
this instance we can keep it as 2gb of
memory for the virtual machine instance
similarly we can use the number of
processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use one processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as well
hard disk is pre-set up as the scsi
hardest and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at all
cd id dvd this is where the installation
file comes
you can think of the iso file that we
downloaded as a pen drive or a usb thumb
drive which is necessary to install an
operating system to provide this we're
going to select use iso image file
we're going to click on browse
go and go to downloads
and select the im so file over here
select open
and we can see it is already loaded up
next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use nat
this helps the virtual machine to draw
the internet from the host machine
settings if your host machine is
connected to the internet then the
virtual machine is connected as well
there are some other options such as
host only or custom segments or lan
segments but those are not necessary for
installation
rest of them are pretty standard which
do not need any extra configuration and
can be left as it is
press ok and now we can power on this
virtual machine
in this screen we can choose how we want
to proceed with the installation
we have a start installer option over
here
so we're going to press enter on that
we're going to wait for the things to
load from the iso file
the first step in the installation is
choosing the language of the operating
system
for this we can go with english as
standard
this is a location this will be used for
setting up the time and some of the
internal settings which depend entirely
on the location of the user
so for this we're going to go with india
configuring the keyboard it's always
recommended to go with the american
english first many people make a mistake
of going with the indian keyboard if it
is possible and it provides a lot of
issues later on so it's always preferred
to go with the american english and if
later we see some necessity of another
keyboard dialect that is required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with american english as a
basic
at this point it's going to load the
installation components from the dot iso
file
it is a big file of 3.6 gb so it has a
lot of components that need to be put
into the virtual machine which can also
be used to detect hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the iso file we
want to write a host name for the system
this host name can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a lan cable let's say if we
use the name kali
domain name you we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation
this is the full name for the user
let's say we can provide the name as
simply learn as a full name
next we're going to set up a username
this username is going to be necessary
to identify the user from its root
accounts and the subsequent below
accounts
for now we can give it as something as
simply123
now we have to choose a password for the
user now remember since this is the
first user that is being added onto this
newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator
we can use whichever password we like
over here
and use the same password below and
press on continue
at this point it's going to detect on
the components on which the operating
system can be installed
like here
there are multiple options like the use
entire disk use entire disk and setup
lvm this entire disk can set up
encrypted lvm for newcomers it is
recommended to just use the first one
since lvm encryption is something that
you can learn afterwards when you are
much more hands-on with the linux
operating system for now we're going to
use the use entire disk guided
installation and press on continue
when we set up the virtual machine on
vmware we had set up a disk capacity
that we gave our purpose 20 gb that is
the hard disk which is being discovered
here even though it is a virtual disk
on vmware it acts as a normal hard disk
on which an operating system can be
installed
so we select this one and press on
continue
here there is a multiple partition
system
all the operating systems that are
installed have different components one
is used for the keeping of the
applications one for the files other for
the ram management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one partition
and we're going to select that and press
on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
gb and a logical partition of 1 gb used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine
we can press on finish partitioning and
write changes to disk
and continue
it's just a confirmation page as you can
see it's wrote that scsi3 is our virtual
hard disk of 20 gb disk capacity
we write the changes to the disk
we press yes and click on continue
at this point the installation has
started now this installation will take
a while depending on the
amount of ram provided the processor is
provided and how quickly the performance
of the system is being hampered by the
host machine on quicker systems this
will be rather quick while on the
smaller ones this will take a while
since this is going to take some time to
install as it is being run on a virtual
machine with only 2 gb of ram we're
going to speed up this part of the video
so we don't have to waste any more time
just watching the progress bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on linux operating systems is
similar to the google play store on
android mobile devices and on the app
store for the apple devices
it's an interface to install external
applications which are not installed by
default let's say for google chrome or
any other browser which can be used to
browse the internet
at this point of time is ask us to
select a network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next
it's going to ask us for a http proxy
which we can leave it as blank and press
it as continue forward
at this point of time it's looking for
updates to the kali linux installation
this will fetch the new builds from the
kali server so the installation is
always updated to the latest version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub boot loader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up
its core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it has installed the grub
bootloader to your primary dive we can
select as yes and press continue
remember the installation was conducted
on dev sda
so we're going to select installation of
the loader on the same hard disk that we
have configured
we press this one and press continue
so now the grub bootloader is being
installed
the grub is highly essential because it
is it shows the motherboard where to
start the operating system from even if
the operating system is installed
correctly and all the files are in
correct order
the absence of a bootloader will not be
able to launch the os properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete
so now we can press on continue
and it's going to finalize the changes
now you can see kali linux being booted
up straight away it doesn't check for
the iso file anymore since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up before
and we have the kali linux system booted
up
and this is your homepage
we can see the installed applications
over here which are being used for
penetration testing by multiple security
analysts worldwide
all of these come pre-installed with
kali linux and others can be installed
using the apt package manager that we
had configured
we can see a full name over here
and with this our installation of the
kali linux is complete
hope you learned something new if you
have any questions regarding this
problem or how to install kali linux
further using normal machines or any
other operating system feel free to ask
us your questions in the comment section
and we will get back to you thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here